et voilà grand prix de propreté juges
désignés
émile quand pas à ça pour une belle
affiche c'est une jour facteurs
jean-françois ou qu'est-ce qui vous a je
viens de nettoyer mon grenier y avait
plein de vieux objets tout poussiéreux
je me suis bien amusé mais je crois que
j'ai jamais été aussi sale
pour sûr ça tombe mal sain et pourquoi
qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui on va
vous alors vous voulez vraiment pas de
mémoire
regardez grand prix de propreté et juges
désignés émis le cambouis 20 je l'avais
complètement oublié vous savez le le
plus peiné ce sera casimir 1 le lui lui
qui vous porte si au 1 mai il sera
vraiment déçu il croit que je suis
toujours parfait alors quand il va voir
que j'ai oublié le grand prix de
propreté ou y médite don d'un autre côté
c'est pas plus mal comme ça
il verra que tout le monde peut faire
des erreurs pour sûr ça donc je discute
pas mais vous voilà et ce après leur
donner un casimir mais qu'est ce qui
t'arrive casimir
regarde moi bah oui je te vois casimir
mais tu es tout seul oui juste le jour
en plus de propreté mais c'est justement
à cause du grand prix mais mes enfants
calme-toi casimir qu'est ce qui s'est
passé tout à l'heure j'étais très propre
et et puis j'ai rencontré monsieur du
snob qu'il était plus propre que moi
alors
casimir casimir toi tu nous as fait
quelque chose de très mal an non j'ai
simplement mis sur sa porte
oui un grand saut avec de la colle et
des vieux papiers à à oslo avec de l'est
et c'est toi qui a reçu le sceau sur la
tête toi aussi tu m'a reçue à sochaux 1
à 20 dans nos machines est jeune et
nettoyer mon grenier et j'avais
complètement oublié que c'était le jour
du grand prix de propreté
je crois que vous avez juste le temps le
concours a lieu que dans un moment alors
allez vite vous nettoyer et à tout à
l'heure en libérateur on va nettoyer
[Applaudissements]
cela pour ce fait les oreilles très bien
celle-là a fait des facteurs
j'aimerais oui alors à tomber jacques
oui s'appelle et moi et moi
regardez silva françois j'arrive juste
accord casimir parce que j'avais terminé
sa chute
j'ai eu peur d'être en retard pays dont
casimir pouvoir marcher tout comme ça là
comme ça l'est comme cela pour quoi mais
c'est pour ne pas soulever de la
poussière qui risquerait de me salir
il faut dire que tu vraiment propre je
ne t'ai jamais vu un si oui bon ben
alors j'ai gagné ah non non non il faut
que je t'ai exalead
bon là allons-y je médite water oui
comment désigner vu le vin
on sait très simple je décerne plusieurs
pays 10e et un pour chaque partie du
corps inscriptions et règlement des
carrés et bien ensuite expliqué ensuite
j'ai ensuite j'additionne jeu tout en
grèce où les points remportés par les
concurrents et celui canal+ va à gagner
automatiquement le le grand prix de
propre évidemment pas les y penser
format large à la wii
excuse moi alors première catégorie
première est [ __ ] cheveux les plus
propres mais quasi merci m tu n'as pas
de cheveux j'en suis désolé tu ne peut
pas concourir au moi même catégorie
comme on attends attends attends voyons
la deuxième catégorie les oreilles les
plus propres mais casimir tu n'a pas
d'oreille
vous savez bien pour les kazemi riches
n'ont jamais eu une oreille je suis
complètement désolé troisième qui l'a
fait venir c'est pas de chance
voyons plus la troisième catégorie ni
dans les plus propres
alors mon trotter dans casimir
enfin enfin factor vous savez très bien
que casimir n'a pas dedans et un gignac
seul en lice et robin je suis assez
d'accord avec vous bon attendez je crois
qu'il avait voulu oui voilà il ya une
dernière catégorie à bord ou celle là va
peut-être sauvé kazemi la main et les
cinq doigts mais ce n'est que 4e droit
mais c'est pas ton droit à casimir cette
ombre
enfin le règlement dit bien cinq doigts
oui par écouter on rencontre également
une très belle fait vrai vous avez
raison
casini a été éliminé une façon
totalement injuste ne peut rien y faire
des trous toit du temps euros le
règlement c'est le règlement du cinéma
alors évidemment aller via quel génie
rien ray avec moi ou reboot casimir
casimir nous pour nous tous le plus
propre
c'est toi maintenant donc telle
vainqueur cheyrou oui oui même si j'ai
un entraînement rapporté quand il ya
quelques lignes que je n'ai pas lu ou
des mois ci un concurrent n'a pas de
cheveux dit dedans ni d'aurel et qu'il
n'a que quatre doigts on pourra les
remplacer par des taches rouges grave
mais jamais la crise rien à y en a et
des taches jaunes aguilar est hélas et
une crête rouge un renvoi l'avocat zehir
bravo je te désigne comme le vainqueur
du grand prix de propos tes bras hu
[Applaudissements]
c'est alors qu'est ce que j'ai gagné à
tanger j'ai la liste et la liste des
prix et qu'il ya quelqu'un une brosse à
cheveux une prends ça dans de jolies
boucles d'oreilles et un peigne en
écales au nom waouh
[Musique]